the devastation from last year's
wildfires in Southwestern France is
clear but less visible is what's
happening underground near the town of
hostens a fire has been burning beneath
the Earth at the site of an old brown
coal Reserve since July this forest
ranger says it was ignited by the
Blazers above ground but no one knows
how to extinguish it so it's checked
every day
there's risk that fires could start
again in these hot spots as the
conditions change as it gets warmer and
dry vantries or leaves could burn
underground fires are rare in France but
wildfires are increasingly common last
years with some of the worst on record
fueled by record temperatures and
drought 30 000 hectares of forest was
destroyed in the southwest alone the
mayor of Hosten says he's never seen
anything like it
we saw some firefighters crying because
they'd never dealt with such a
terrifying situation some feared that
they could die this whole area was
covered with trees and what people who
live in this region are really worried
about is the possibility of another
summer of devastating wildfires because
there's been very little rainfall this
year the ground is really dry and it's
getting hotter
the French government says the
Situation's urgent it's launched a
wildfire action plan extra water
carrying aircraft are being brought in
and more firefighters mobilized
last year we saw many regions had large
forest fires for the first time
including the Jura or even Brittany for
us it's a clear sign of climate change
while preparation is essential some
environmentalists say that unless more
is done to tackle climate change more
forests will be lost to wildfires each
year and more homes and lives put at
risk Natasha Butler Al Jazeera hostens
Southwest France